[Music]
about five or six years ago christian
and i made our first short which you can
see actually on the other cabin dot com
if you go there it's called abe nike and
uh some friends of ours were very kind
to participate in it including eddie k
thomas at one point we were shooting a
scene where eddie was across a subway
platform we were in queens i believe
brooklyn i think brooklyn i was on one
side with a camera and eddie and other
actress megan ketch were on the other
alone on the other side of the platform
and on my side a bunch of
kids teenagers they spotted me they they
recognized me from jeepers creepers they
were excited about jeep scrapers and
then they i think maybe i pointed out
eddie or one of them noticed eddie to to
deflect from the attention you were
getting yes yes
that's key and um which is a selfish
move on my part and when they noticed
him
they were trying to place him and then
finally one of them said uh
oh my god you [ __ ] stiffler's moms
they were yelling did you [ __ ]
stiffler's mom over and over again and i
saw him register
a way to
answer them yeah and you know i i saw
him do the like the mental mass of like
how do i yell this across the platform
and he just goes
yep yeah yeah and he's like nodded and
waved
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your host justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
and with me as always as always i've
never not been with you uh yeah that's
true i've not been with you for a couple
of years that's true too
boring yeah yeah i didn't know what to
do with myself um
but there were formative years i was
learning some key things i was learning
how to uh you know urinate in a toilet
that's funny i i never realized that
those three plus years you were on the
planet before me yeah you accomplished
so much yeah my mother is very head
start you got our mother's upset now
because she feels like her grandchild
our nephews aren't remembering her we're
all quarantined and they've been seeing
each other on facetime and she's
heartbroken that uh our nephew
who's two yeah he doesn't quite he
doesn't get my point to her was i've
been trying to talk her off the ledge
because he doesn't really get excited he
really likes us a lot and gets excited
in person when he sees us but on
facetime it doesn't really translate i
just think there's a disconnect yeah i
think
he doesn't understand the connection
between someone who's he's talking to on
facetime and somebody's talking to in
real life right
that's what i would think and i tried to
he has the kind of vacant look
on facetime i see that he doesn't really
understand what's happening well this is
a whole new thing for i mean we didn't
have to deal with that when we were kids
i wouldn't know i i don't know what it
was like to have that two-year-old brain
um
i just now know what it's like to have a
five-year-old brain um but what are you
talking about two-year-old brain oh
right you're older than me that's that's
why you brought it up oh yeah right um
why would we talk where are we talking
about eddie k thomas that day i'll tell
you why his co-star is in this movie
that we're referencing with
stiffler and stifler's mom and band cam
let me explain the movie for those of
you who don't know it's it's a little uh
indie called american pie
and his co-star in that movie one of the
other one of his friends in the movie
jim who played jim
is our guest today on the show uh jason
biggs one of my favorites um
i've known jason for a long time not
well i've never known him well but every
time i see him every time we've hung out
the few times we've hung out uh i just
always had the best time with him he's
just such a fun hang and uh
he's also great in that movie he's of
course he's of course most known for
that movie but he's also done a lot of
other great work he's in orange is the
new black and
some
cult films from the early 2000s that are
that remain
uh nostalgic yes great like remember um
what's that move loser loser amy
heckerling directed such a good movie
really good movie
yeah um
i have to rewatch some of those i
haven't seen those movies in a long time
or or boys and girls the freddie prince
jr i think we talk about that uh jason's
just been around for you know years and
he was right before i started acting he
had just american pie i think it just
come out so
i owe him and all those guys in that
movie and girls um
a lot because
that movie was was one of the key
elements of of starting that whole teen
movie boom that movie changed so much
that you guys talk about this but that
yeah that r-rated teen comedy right it
was so smart how they
marketed that i know risky
yeah but it was universal as a major
studio how it paid off it's amazing how
how that risk paid off though you guys
talk about it so i don't get into it but
oh that's like something i would do i
know
tables and turns what do you mean [ __ ]
but that movie is important to me not
that it's my favorite movie of all time
but oh i'm dying to hear this well
here's my here's my connection to it
that movie is about a graduating high
school class
the class of 1999 and it came out in
june of 1999 and the whole movie is
about oh yeah it's your year
yeah the end of high school and that was
my class that's right class of 99. so i
always felt a
connection to that movie and those
characters yeah jason is also known for
being
really putting himself out there being
very brave uh
kind of doing anything for a laugh which
i
really like making love to a pie yes
it doesn't get no zanier than that uh
and and i think that's really brave of
him and i think oftentimes he doesn't
get enough credit for
being that bold um with with his
performances and uh we actually talk
about that in the context of kathleen
turner and with whom he did
the play the graduate with and so we'll
get into that and jason's
long career we're going to talk about
that and many other things with the
pie fornicating
yeah sure classier way of saying it
but it's so much more than that and we
talk about uh all of those things uh
with just a very funny
really great jason biggs
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
what would the male equivalent of sultry
be like barry white or somebody yeah
what is that i mean what do you call it
what do you call that
rich
rich but it's not you you don't say
sultry about a man i guess not but can't
you yeah i guess you well let's say
yeah i was gonna say once you put the
headphones on your voice got a little
sultrier and i feel like mine did too
maybe maybe we're just now more aware of
our voice i think that's what it is it's
funny i was watching um
a comedian uh joe coy you know joe coy
super funny dude and i saw my friend of
mine went to his concert the other night
and boys to men opened up for them and i
noticed it was just three boys
who are now men who are now men yeah
three men but but the one dude who's the
sultry voice guy oh he was gone the
talker
the talker was oh yeah you know what i'm
talking about baby yeah baby yeah yeah
until the end of the road is the famous
one where at like halfway through the
song it's just him talking for like 10
minutes oh really come on baby you know
it's just coke
you know how hard this is for me oh the
guys in the background are like that's
so funny there was a manhattan song um
it's a breakup song and the whole you
got to hear this and the whole beginning
is like maybe i asked you here today to
talk to you about some things that are
very and like
the whole point of it is like this is
going to be harder for me so much harder
for me than it is for you
i'm going to let you down it's sort of
like self-congratulatory like i'm a good
person for doing this so nobly
uh [ __ ] i wish i could remember the name
but for a while
this is name drop the vince the after
vince vaughn was obsessed with it and
vince would drive around l.a
blasting it and lip syncing to it he'd
pull up next to people like wait like
that's great it was amazing they'd be
waiting in line at like pinks or some
club or like avalon or something and
he'd roll down this window and he'd just
be like babe i asked you here today to
tell you about some things that i gotta
touch that's pretty brilliant it was
really funny thank you for the avalon
drop by the way remember that oh my god
room upstairs spider sarah pantera she
comes up a lot of times
yeah
absolutely what were those days like for
you would go out okay i remember we went
out a lot
okay we went out
i tiptoed around yeah no
you had a moment where you enjoyed
yourself
there was a minute right were you i
thought i saw you once uh dude we
partied our faces off we went out a ton
so like
yeah early aughts
really odds moved to la 97 from new york
american pie happened the next year wow
and i turned 21 per it was all the
timing was all just yeah the best was a
great time to be an actor to be a young
actor dude and thanks to your i mean
really like that was one of the movies
that that you know that hit but it was
there were so many things right i mean
dude i was auditioning for
so much yeah it was insane yeah right
and like yeah i would have been psyched
on any single one of those jobs yeah
yeah you know did you have any idea it
was wasn't it called the great falls it
was at one point the original script
that i had gotten sent to me was called
um
untitled teenage sex comedy
that oh yeah that studios will probably
hate but we think you will like that can
be made for under 10 million that's
right that was literally registered with
the wga west oh that's the script that i
saw and so i got that now meanwhile all
these other scripts you know
no offense standing but there were you
know it was like they fought whatever
yeah yeah okay new teen comedy title and
whatever it was yeah okay cool and then
you read it and you go oh he's like here
we go there's freddy prince and then
i'll be the best friend yeah you know
you know it's like all fine and great
and i did one of those and was psyched
on it oh yeah no but was that boys and
girls boys and girls yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah well that was before american pie
it was actually right actually i'm my
chronology is wrong
but
i thought so because i didn't write your
notes i don't have my notes in front of
me i uh it was it was right after in
fact that was part of a deal i made with
harvey
harvey firestone harvey fierstein yeah
speaking of sultry yeah
there's an example oh my god oh my god
oh my god that's right because the remax
made all those made all of them made so
many of them man it was right before so
american pie was about to come out in
the summer of 99
and it had like hype around it and there
was hype yeah and
harvey and uh bob were making
particularly under their dimensions
scream and all these other and teen
movies and how to deal with freddie
prinz wanted to meet with me and you
know let's to to their credit you know
they were like we think american pie is
going to be big and we want to sign you
to a thing and yeah they signed me to a
two picture thing like before american
pike i was like this is [ __ ] cool
must have anyway been i mean
yeah and they were making oscar winning
that was like shakespeare in love here
yeah you go oh okay yeah of course i
mean in a good way i think history will
will treat them
when i say fairly i don't mean like
they'll be nice to them i think that
they'll obviously treat them the way
they deserve to be treated um but i
think what might get lost in that
narrative and what probably should is
yeah it doesn't matter if it does yeah
yeah it's it's such a moot point but um
yeah that must have been exciting to
have those guys oh my god valentine's
time you were just like what what is
that funny yeah yeah so um so it
actually was after uh american pie but
um but but still it was scripts like
that you know that you're reading and
you go oh dude i wish please god i would
love and then and then that thing comes
across and you read this title and you
go oh [ __ ] like talk about standing out
from there oh yeah you know what i mean
smart actually very smart um did and did
it the script itself did it field
yeah yeah yeah yeah it really did i mean
some of those scenes which were all in
there the the pie scene the you know the
opening scene where i'm masturbating
with scrambled porn i mean that's all in
that script and you go this is not
the pg-13 [ __ ] that i've been reading
for the last six years right it was a
lot of pg-13 stuff i i did a pg-13
college movie and it's
it was so frustrating there was an
r-rated version that was so much better
we were so excited of course and but
it's hard you can't tell that an
authentic teenage experience uh in a
pg-13 way i think you can say one
[ __ ] i think you get yeah one [ __ ] and
then and it can't be in a sexual context
you can't say like you can say like in a
frustrated way right [ __ ] uh you [ __ ]
i'm going to make love to you you [ __ ]
um you'd have to
just say
yeah oh man that's so
there was we were never and that that's
what was um exciting too because the
studio from the beginning was universal
that from the beginning they were like
yeah we know this isn't a pg-13 we're
not going to do that but what actually
ended up happening was
something like you don't quote me on
this but i've already lied to you about
the chronology of my career uh but
something like four cuts of the movie
got nc17 oh and they had and yeah and
they had to keep so we were that's what
we were fighting the other side of it we
weren't trying to like make it go from r
to p 13. we were trying to get it from
nc 17 to r oh my on one of the things
wow and this is a fact one of the
reasons in the end that the nc7
kept making it nc 17 was the number and
that they were going to go it's a
negotiation you know yeah stuff they had
there's not like there is a guidebook
but right we don't know it's like a
board yeah
it's like 15 people isn't it like a cup
like a couple like a dozen people not a
lot yeah and they're going
no i haven't seen this before but this
feels like not at all i need to
so
it was the number of threats
oh really into the pie you're kidding
the number of times because there's no
precedent for that no
there's no book that says if the guy's
if an actor is [ __ ] a brother of all
these movies
it actors have [ __ ] angel food cake
various other baked goods but no
precedent so it was the number of
thrusts that they could show of me
actually moving into the pie and then
like you think how did they come up with
that who who am i on the board like
and then you go yeah and you go also
like okay so they're doing it
theoretically to protect a certain
audience right the pie lovers the pie
lovers yeah um bakers bakers what have
you um
the you the bakers union mostly the
[Applause]
yeah can see two thrusts but they can't
see six
or five like that's gonna that is going
to yeah that's where you start to enter
their brain in a way that is unhealthy
yeah once they see more than two or
three like whatever it's saying it's so
arbitrary yeah and weird but that's
right that was the thing that's crazy
big thing and we wore it at like a as a
point of pride it was a point of pride
for all of us yeah we were psyched like
yeah this was nc 17 for three months
yeah it's kind of cool you're also that
age where it's like that's kind of cool
when it's totally yeah totally wow so
and all that's and this stuff is done so
um
another difference i think it was it was
acted and directed in a much more
authentic way than a lot of those
movies were i love porkys and revenge
the nerds and but a lot of that was like
there was there's some cartoonish
elements yeah yeah yeah whereas felt
more authentic to a teen experience yeah
obviously you have these scenes that are
pretty wild and crazy but it they also
felt like they were earned and like
you know like kids do weird things i
never [ __ ] a pie but i remember what
trying to do
sure yeah to this day yeah um i you know
depending on the inside the filling um
obviously
right after the movie came out about a
kid in idaho of course
classic idaho classic idaho and mistake
got third degree burns on his dick third
yeah oh that's like gotta wait for it to
cool off bro you gotta put it on the
windowsill
let the birds chirp you know like let
this but then but then you lose your
your yeah gum [ __ ] your mojo yeah
you see those little cartoon birds
flutter yeah
that's true third degree burns that's
like that's real that's like that's real
they're listening by the way that was
just the one that we read about you know
right i was the only one that got
pregnant
i mean this was i mean it was like
internet ish well people write into the
show often so if anyone had a similar
experience it doesn't have to be third
degree burns doesn't have to be third
degree it doesn't even have to be a pie
i'd like to just hear
i mean that's what i'm sure you you
would get to ask that question although
like what else would you if you did what
pie would you like yeah you know i want
to get still to this day all the all the
time is do you do you eat pie will you
eat pie you know why would you not or
what is your favorite or what is your
favorite pie not not just and then my
sort of it's now become a bit rote but
my response to when people ask if i eat
uh what my favorite pie is i said well
it depends for eating or [ __ ]
that's true you just got to embrace it
bro 20 [ __ ] years of this [ __ ] man
well i was gonna say
you haven't aged much so so you must get
recognized still a lot before that yeah
yeah yeah for sure um the movie came out
on friday night obviously and then the
next morning saturday first of all
before that there was already this like
weird kind of buzz not weird but it
looked like a real sort it was like a
summer movie it was a summer movie yeah
that was originally supposed to be in
april they were gonna like you know just
put it out in the spring
you know
yeah i think we may want to so it had
all this momentum yes too i remember you
guys were on the cover of like rolling
yeah yeah it was crazy man it was crazy
and um
so
there was the but the thing that people
forget about um
because now we're sort of anesthetized
to it and also
with the internet i just feel like
yeah it's not as big a thing but at the
time in the spring before the movie came
out they released a red band trailer and
the red bands and that was kind of new
it was new and it was different no one
ever did a red band you don't want your
trailer to be an r you know the actual
trailer was rated r meaning it could
only show before r-rated movies oh but
they leaned into it they've totally
leaned into it and that and you know you
you sit down at the movie theater and
you just got one green following preview
yeah green and then a movie green green
everyone is so familiar with it and then
the red thing pops up and everyone goes
wait what is that what the [ __ ] is this
and then the thing happens and the
reason it was redman is because they
showed they chose smartly to not save
the pie [ __ ] for
the thing they showed it they showed me
[ __ ] the pie just a quick shot of it
but it was you know eugene walked in and
sees me and that was in the trailer and
people went holy [ __ ] like so there was
this sort of buzz before it ever came
out anyway i digress so well it was such
a it was such a
shocking journey to have them in a movie
that like not only it's not like it
spoils the movie you want to see in what
context did that happen and like what
else is going to happen exactly yeah and
we and you know and the the beauty of
the movie i think is like there was
other [ __ ] yeah yeah you know alison's
line of like the flu and i mean there's
so much [ __ ] that you just go what at
the time yeah people went what the [ __ ]
yeah and like heartfelt stuff dude it
wasn't just like it was all done in a
very authentic grounded way yeah
um and that's a credit to the writer
initially of course because the script
felt that way from the beginning but um
chris and paul white's who that's right
who were so and you know if you look at
their resumes now you know you get you
think oh the directors of american pie
you can take a if you know you you could
one could guess like oh their career
would go this way then they did about a
boy without a boy and
one did uh they split up a little bit
one did the chronicles of narnia and
like they're just super smart
cool um
very sensitive
yes and so um
anyway but we had them at the helm so
they kept it grounded and then the cast
too man it was a very like real you know
kind of kind of cast but um did you know
any of them beforehand so eddie k thomas
i knew oh you did oh yeah so eddie and i
were auditioning in new york since we
were little kids right cause you were on
a soap right in new york i was uh on a
soap i'd done some stuff even before
that but the soap opera is funny because
i was i was a i was a regular series
regular on the soap opera as the world
turns here in 94 and eddie who had
already known because he started acting
when he was
eight so i would have been i started a
few years before that but when he was
eight i was ten so that's when we first
met on every audition wow whatever we
weren't really friends we just knew we
should we see each other yeah he was a
city kid i would go home to bergen
county in new jersey so i'd get back in
my mom's minivan
home whereas he would you know hang with
his his uh new york city kid and friends
and like get on the subways which is why
he always felt to me i've known him for
years a little more like kind of well
finch is like that the characters was
like
more evo evolved
very yeah exactly so that's that's funny
but we were friendly you know i mean we
[ __ ] knew each other we see each
other
100 times a year you know whatever on
auditions and then on the actually the
soap opera he was an extra in one of the
scenes
one of my scenes there was like a high
school scene where i get like beat up
and he's like one of the kids in the
background like coming to beat me oh
really yeah
random [ __ ] like that would happen in
our in our sort of early days funny yeah
and then we had the same agent when we
both auditioned for american pie and
then and you did a play with judd hirsch
when you were a kid yeah so that's when
i was younger that was uh wow i first
did it when i was in uh
it was 1990 when i first did it and then
we went to uh seattle and it was my
first like big chunk of time
like on a job away like on location i
was we did it at the seattle repertory
theater for like three months me and my
mom went and lived there it was super
cool you loved that
from an early age you really liked it
yeah i loved it wow i mean i definitely
got i love the validation still do you
know
well i think you're great well thanks
buddy yeah uh and this is oh i'm done
i'm actually waiting for you to try this
is the best interview ever and then i
can go
oh you had less time than i thought
um uh uh yeah you never when you were a
kid you weren't you wouldn't get nervous
i see that always amazes me about young
like the thing man like when i think
about my nerves i i feel like i get way
like now i get nervous really really
nervous i i remember when i did
uh so that's when i so i did that in
seattle and then brought it to broadway
the following year and i don't
remember opening night for me um i don't
remember feeling those nerves i remember
feeling excitement
um
but every but more than anything i felt
very comfortable it was a smaller role
it wasn't like the play was on my
shoulders
it was called conversations with my
father tony
judd hirsch um david crumholtz oh my god
outside outside of bye bye birdie and
flushing you know flushing middle school
yeah
forest hills forest hills sorry he was
far sales uh yeah so it was a different
kid it was there's two young kid roles
in it and it was a different kid that
did it in seattle and then he didn't
come and do it on broadway so they cast
it spread this wide net
and
i just thought chromos was acting for
the time he left the womb you know he
just seems like he was right yeah like
an infant actor i mean
he was it's just he wasn't getting paid
right do it i mean he
is
genius he's genius yeah so this was his
first thing david crumbles for those of
you
if anyone's listening uh was in um
his big thing when he was a kid he was
in the santa claus he played the club
and the um adam's family with christian
family he was like
life with mikey so life with mikey he
booked when we were doing conversations
with my father oh wow i remember being
like jealous yeah that must have been
something everyone every kid in new york
i not only auditioned for but it was
like i had been already you know like
acting for a while and i've been like on
all these commercials and you were like
a salty old
and but by the way he was and is genius
yeah yeah yeah still it's you know yeah
and um but i remember that was my first
time where i felt like a sense of oh
like competitiveness and sort of envy
you know it wasn't a good feeling i'm
not proud of it but i certainly
identified it totally yeah you know and
um
uh that's interesting and what's great
is i've i ended up re-hooking up with
david many years later and um and i just
love him yeah i love him you know so
it's like there's a there's a pride
where did you guys shot that in canada
no we shot it in l.a man
all of the um no kidding all so the
first
three
yeah so the first one was long beach was
a lot of it so like my jim's house was
in long beach so like a lot of like long
beach stuff but then deep valley was
this like for the first movie we
we shot in this converted warehouse that
had no air conditioning as we built sets
in there like my bedroom was and stuff
oh my god it was a thousand degrees
there's like a sheen to everyone yep oh
my god yeah oh [ __ ]
it was so hot dude makeup couldn't keep
up with it it was insane that's where we
did the scene with uh shannon where sh
you know the computer scene where she
gets naked and
the whole thing was it was tight and
weird but everything was in la second
movie same thing everything in l.a the
second movie was probably a lot more
comfortable a lot more comfortable yeah
we had a better way out of fact i think
we shot some on the universal live wow
but we had um
that was the in in part two we go to the
lake house lake michigan yes we rent a
house for the summer and no we did it uh
in malibu paradise cove they built a
facade
and put plopped it down on the beach oh
the interiors were shot in the sound
stage it was right yeah and and we were
like oh there's waves here and they were
like i've never been to michigan at that
point you know they're like no no lake
michigan actually has it does yeah and
people from michigan
thought we had shot unlike michigan so
you just have to avoid palm trees and
stuff exactly right that's exactly right
that was our big thing was avoiding palm
trees oh i remember that being a thing
from one to two what else did people
change drastically in the cast were
there like changes in behavior and stuff
um
not
noted not really no i mean the guys know
like our group of uh you all got so
famous yeah it all happened pretty
intensely and quickly but because it was
a shared experience i feel like and
everyone was cool and honestly the first
american pie was great
for us um because we were at the age and
i think because of the subject matter
and because we were all so excited to be
there that it really bonded us in a way
we had so much it was summer camp yeah
you know what i mean it was just one of
those experiences yeah and so
to come back for the second one there
was no room for attitude or anything you
know i think like it would have been
exposed yeah it was like myself and like
chris klein had like kind of gotten a
bunch of he
yeah and then like shawn you know sean
blew up but everyone to an extent yeah
you know what i mean everyone kind of
kind of blew up but but everyone was
cool and nice i mean i don't know if
you've met chris he's super chill yeah
um uh you know sean is plucked out of
obscure i mean he was he's a student yes
exactly for election that movie election
he's so good but he is that kid he is
that midwestern like wide-eyed and
potatoes wide eyes golden retriever
puppy just like oh my god yeah that's
the best way to describe it yeah and he
has not changed oh really
not one bit you know and really he's you
know been on a path and you know he's
the nicest guy super chill yeah um
look alison
had already
she was already on buffy that's right
she was already like a tv star right you
know and who came in and shot the first
american pie her scenes were like three
days or four days same with eugene no
kidding they were eating all that camp
stuff that's three that was part two oh
oh oh oh the first movie was like two
one scene in a classroom oh my god uh
where i asked her out to the prom after
my debacle on the internet yeah um there
was obviously the prom scene there was
the post-prom scene and maybe one more
establishing scene before i asked her
out wow but that was you know i mean you
think yeah wow she's in it throughout
but eugene too eugene had like four days
or three days what's all in your your
bedroom and the house i guess there's
not a lot of locations wow
you must have been a fan of his going on
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah my dad and i used
to watch it um
yeah huge favorite who wants to buy my
nails i i
i loved him so much splash splash oh
he's ugh brilliant armed and dangerous
yeah
yeah sure
i mean meg ryan john candy
of uh
yeah yeah scrambled pork you'd watch
those for like the boobs specifically
like remember
our parents friends had
cable and they had the scrambled channel
but i remember
watching it because every once in a
while it'd be like i think i see a
nipple it might be a testicle yeah but
it's still pretty crazy to see it was
great oh that's why that scene was so
real i know i know and by the way i was
19 when i shot that i mean i was only
two years removed from sitting in my
friend's basement watching scratch spice
channel that's funny you know i was like
yeah yeah i can write i know this is
correct i can do this life could be a
dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]
were there a lot of auditions leading up
to that was that a tough job to get the
americans uh auditions for that
for that movie um it actually it was a
tough job to get but there weren't many
auditions i read for casting
read for chris and paul
you know the feeling of crushing it yeah
yeah you felt good
and you could and then you can tell when
they are like oh yeah yeah right and i
left there those were my only auditions
wow but
but then the crazy then then the like
[ __ ] nail biting happened because um
i
got word that the directors love me and
i was their first choice the studio the
studio
yeah studio was deciding did they want
to go
like a name exactly
exactly and the name i had heard at the
time was jonathan taylor-thomas
from who's kind of at the height of uh
uh h h i h
is known commonly yeah
that was that was ta's big sitcom um
yeah zachary i remember jonathan yeah he
was a huge star yeah and but you said
zach exactly brian yeah those guys were
wow prime dude from the time i was i had
that call back and knew that i was
first choice oh man
to the time that
it was okay jonathan's not doing it or
i don't know if he said no because there
was also the conversation i mean i would
have these conversations every day with
my manager at the time just going like
well you know or he would say you know
well it's it's not really i'm getting
word that jonathan's concerned because
it doesn't fall into his wholesome image
you know
certainly didn't certainly didn't yeah
but then i would hear a week later like
ah that's why he likes it he wants to
change it um
[Applause]
uh yeah that's what a feeling and so
remember that term it's going it looks
like it might be going away from you
i'm
it might be going away yep yep and i
didn't find out
probably for at least two months like
until june and then we started shooting
in july like it was a quick like okay
yeah we start in three weeks like of
course they knew that you would do it
right of course yeah yeah they knew they
had me there was no jtt might have
needed time to go to the turks and
caicos or something
yeah i think his boat he was
repositioned yeah
yeah wow so then okay so after it
becomes a success do you feel then
pressure to
what's the to do the next right move and
like
now how do i stay on this
path
not really so i filmed the movie in the
summer of 98. i didn't and then it was a
year before the movie came out yeah in
that year i got offered a arc an arc on
home improvement it was the final season
and it was this big role for like four
episodes like the final four episodes
and
i was i auditioned for it i went in i
was like this is i killed it i was like
this is gonna be fun right on another
cool job my dad loves this show yeah so
dope you know because also everyone back
home in jersey even my parents
you know yeah i shot some little movies
that became that never got seen so they
didn't i was like no really i think this
movie is you're gonna see it yeah but it
didn't right it didn't come totally
but home improvement right i was sure
how many millions of people were
watching i was like yeah yeah
[Laughter]
so um my manager
made me pass
and it was the first time now at this
point this was 98 or whatever and i
started in 83 so 15 years i had been
doing this oh my god
never would i have passed on something
it was such a crazy
foreign idea to me because it was going
to be a big
thing but a lot of people would have
watched watch it but let's let's wait
for this other big thing because this is
you that we want to perform so it's
really smart yeah i have friends who
have had moments of success like that
and and if and some of them
had an understanding or i don't know if
it's how they were raised or they just
had a level of ambition where they
were able to be really patient and pass
and wait for strategic
i the few times i've had moments where
like oh i'm getting offers and work
after work i i never had that no you
know and you say like it's true for
better for worse like yeah who knows you
know who knows who knows i mean i mean
you think about and i'm not comparing
myself to him into as an actor but but
you know heath ledger did uh 10 things i
hate about you the same summer as right
i was speaking of david cromhold i
auditioned for that crumb oh wow and
like it was all the same kind of thing
you auditioned for for the joke levitt
part yeah i have to leave so yeah really
yeah oh yeah he made a conscious
decision yeah i don't want to do team
comedy about any [ __ ] thing yeah you
know and he like waited and i think he
waited like a year of not work to the
patriot exactly yeah exactly right
that's my understanding of it as well so
um again
first of all he had confidence in his
abilities which were of course amazing
so good for him and
i had confidence in my abilities but
less confidence in the industry liking
me yeah forever right do you know what i
mean i was like no no no dude this [ __ ]
is fickle yeah i'm gonna be unemployed
again at some point yes take the [ __ ]
work while i can enjoy that kind of
thing what was it like going back to it
that many years later um
fun yeah yeah like reunion like a
reunion it was a proper reason yeah
some of those people i hadn't seen since
the last wow american pie but a lot had
changed you know as well um
i wasn't a dad yet but i was a husband
i'd gotten married you know
people had become that uh parents out
there as a parent um
you know natasha had gotten sober i mean
there's a lot of like people came to set
we were with changes we were basically
those first three movies we looked back
we were [ __ ] kids yeah yeah kids you
know and then the last movie we came
back and we felt like oh we're
you know it's funny we thought we were
adults yeah that was first right yeah
you try to present something i look back
at some of those interviews i did and
like it's really embarrassing like i
tried i was trying to
sound either cool or like i knew what i
was talking about or com really trying
to sound comfortable right which brings
me to is one of the reasons i love the
bachelor
that's what they're all doing on that
show they're trying to sound either
romantic comfortable
cool whatever their version of like
whatever they want to present to the
world but it's all like
schtick it's all that yeah
yeah and more so over the years you know
i still love the show and i'm actually
not um
this season i haven't been able to watch
much but really i know there goes my
last stream no i know
i listen i'm happy to talk about claire
oh wait oh yeah yeah i'm happy to talk
about is that for sure is that that's
for sure oh yeah that's for sure um but
here's
[Laughter]
here's
so i haven't watched the season but
here's i watched last year they're very
young this year
and the the
it there was a time when the bachelor
slash bachelorette
was mostly populated with
people contestants who really wanted to
find love okay it was the it was the
girl yeah um from small town
massachusetts whose friend
sent in a video for her unbeknownst to
her because she has trouble with guys
and she just got out of a thing
and then oh she's on the show and you go
yeah it felt way more earnest yeah that
was just populated with people who want
to be famous right
which and i don't know what this says
about me or how i watch the show but
it's kind of why i prefer that iteration
i get it i get it i get it because it's
like
totally yeah yeah there was a purity
though to it that that doesn't exist
anymore but the new purity is how badly
they want this other thing which is same
it's so true no it's you're
absolutely right and that's the reason
why i think people are still so drawn to
it and why i am as well yeah um but you
haven't this year
i just haven't been able to because i've
been traveling back and forth and i was
just kids
yeah and a job in l.a yeah yeah i
literally haven't watched a thing but um
does jenny still watch it because you
got you were on it we were on it last
year yes yeah that was so cool speaking
of like so that guy john paul jones
jpg yeah
yeah yeah yeah sure
he
tasha
it's so funny like when we came in and
we hadn't the show hadn't aired yet
right so we hadn't this that was our
introduction to these characters usually
we you know so we're seeing these people
but we don't have the at home you know
the little back stories and the things
and whatever so we're just mean it was
fascinating
to be there and to meet these people and
jenny and i would like like kind of
always pull each other aside and be like
this guy's the so-and-so guy
this is the guy who wants to be the most
famous this is the guy yeah this is he's
he's pretty he's trying to lay on being
a dick yeah he's laying it yeah yeah
yeah this isn't [ __ ] real so he's
that guy oh that's interesting and you
can [ __ ] it's right
because they create their own narratives
they write their own stories they do
essentially yeah but but they're also
there's smart people around them who are
also gone or
turning them in the other direction or
whatever it is oh wow yeah for sure i
mean it's it's masterfully done
masterfully masterfully it's it's a it's
brilliant but yeah it has become you're
so right justin it really is because i'm
fascinated now
by
fame in general um
and how it corrupts people i mean and
how accessible it is yes yes like that's
what's different like when you and i got
our first dose of it it was a different
way it was a movie that hit it was a
thing you know
and it felt
more
for lack of a better word special right
unique well it was also based on
something not to toot our own horns but
it was based on something that was
a talent some sort of right had some
entered uh it required some kind of
skill worked for it not that we're you
know but totally but like
now anyone can acquire it by not it's
just numbers exactly it's all just
numbers exactly and it's and it's um
it's fascinating to see how that's
changed obviously social media um but
television as well yeah like these shows
are now populated with people who you
know if anything like
you know these these contestants they're
they they know once they get on that
that at the very least
it used to be like okay i think if we go
the cycle of like the bachelor first it
was like i want to find love you're
right right then it was like well maybe
i can parlay this maybe i can parlay
this into something another career
people who were like from kansas had a
real estate company that were like okay
well this could help my real estate
company when i'm done on the show right
right then it was like no i'm going to
stay in l.a
when this is over and i'm going to try
to do acting or whatever now the sort of
the safe and
bet and the thing that all of them have
access to is social media and increase
in followers and an ability to monetize
that yeah i'm going to sell energy
drinks yeah yeah it's it's the whole
thing is just really fascinating i just
want to take a break now for our sponsor
um
turbo energy boost uh turbo
you're never down with turbo sorry about
that uh yeah it's crazy it is crazy and
and that's when the roles the
caricatures that they start to play
because they now they're like how do i
stand out it's not about how do i get
her to fall in love with me how do i
stay on this show how do i stay on the
show the longest and how do i [ __ ]
stand out to to people off who are
viewers not her yeah it's very sinister
it actually requires so um
a level of narcissism that that uh to
the point where where your integrity and
any kind of values you have are
completely overwhelmed by your desire to
be known to be known so when you were on
you saw kind of is it like seeing the
man behind yeah a little bit yeah you're
peeking behind the curtain for sure yeah
but
but it was cool it was really fun it was
cool i was
psyched to do it it felt like our you
know super fan
you know it all kind of came full circle
for us
do you like doing that stuff in general
with jenny like she's such a funny smart
person she seems like she'd be obviously
very fun to be with yeah married to but
but like
is it fun to do that publicly that kind
of stuff yeah yeah yeah it is it's funny
we
you have been saying you did a show yeah
we did a radio show on sirius for a
while which was which was fun um you
know it's interesting it's like
it's
kind of everything they tell you i don't
know if you've worked with a girlfriend
or i have i've done movies with them
yeah but
it's hard it's hard maybe maybe married
as well there's like a
i i don't know whatever it is it's uh
it's um do you ever say things in like
regret totally yeah yeah yeah
yes
a million percent
well you know it's like we also
we
we also come to the table for better or
for worse with
different styles and skill sets
that
we
know we should respect the other person
we should sort of defer
example and i'm probably going to get
heat for even saying this if she hears
it um she won't she's not going to okay
yeah um wait what yeah
like uh i'll more improv based i'm more
improv based and she's more she's a
writer right so she's more calculated
more sort of uh deliberate yeah and
sometimes that works great and sometimes
it doesn't but then the moment that you
know one of us might have a suggestion
right like oh babe what about this joke
she's like i i
i got this i got it or it's like oh hey
you know you maybe you should have went
this way with things like ah
you know because
i feel like any other actor or any other
sort of colleague you know you just you
know either i welcome it or i just you
just kind of go oh you internalize it
and move on yeah and it's fine but when
you're married when you're married you
can and do say um you know i don't like
you yeah
you know so we've gotten into some stuff
yeah uh we hosted a game show together
oh yeah what was that oh god it was
called my partner knows best the the
show ended up being
a bit of a mess but uh but we the funny
idea is it's a funny idea a married
couple kind of newlywed gaming yeah yeah
double dare
uh there's a physical component but it
kind of makes sense anyway uh but we
hosted that and again that's where
that's the perfect example where like i
would want to sort of you know i would
interact with the contestants and kind
of be more like let's just she was
sticking more together she was like
here's kind of the things that we should
hit and sometimes we did need to do that
by the way like sometimes that was
important you know so it's usually works
out where it's it's good i mean with
what you bring together it'll look good
in the end right but they're most often
bumpy to get there uh it's sometimes
bumpy to get there we're not like we're
not the
most uh we have so much fun together and
she is the funniest person i know um it
seems like it but yeah but we're not
like this sort of like it's not like a
well-oiled machine
no no no we always have little kinks man
it's definitely like
it's a it's a bit of a grind but we love
it jenny's carved this out all on her
own you know she i met her
13 whatever years ago
as she was an actress like a lot of
actresses in la you know was having ups
and downs and
she's one of the funniest people i mean
she was struck by how funny she was the
moment i met her yeah um but here was
this girl who was trying to do very
dark indie movies and like you know
doing guest stars on the csis and the
you know all these sort of procedurals
one hours playing the you know the the
the heroin the heroin addict the
prisoner who's lost who's getting
separated from her child and a big
crying scene and all this stuff and then
twitter came along
and
she started she took to twitter and
started writing jokes basically used it
as this platform yeah to sort of show
her authentic self which is very funny
very uh and actually the bachelor played
a huge role in that because we would
live tweet the bachelor together sort of
one of our early sort of things that
people kind of got psyched on and they
would follow jenny for the bachelor okay
right and so and she would make these
snarky comments about all the
contestants some of which you probably
can't say today
oh man but she
just grew this following yeah massive
you know following and from that i think
it was playboy was the first place they
asked her to write an article
um so she wrote this hilarious essay
then she wrote more for them and then
other publications marie claire some
other you know spots and then um from
the essays
she now had a collection of essays she
sold the book wow and so she then the
book became a new york times bestseller
and then she sold that back to and then
she was like kind of like yeah [ __ ]
hollywood but then of course she like
sold the rights back to hollywood and
wrote this play because she still is
sure you know she's in hollywood you
know and and probably still enjoys
acting like still enjoys it when it's
her stuff right so like so like her
first book we sold to abc and didn't get
picked up as pilot but they gave us a
deal her a deal to do uh it digitally so
we did like 10 episodes for abc abc
digital which kind of came and went uh
it's called i like uh no yeah i like you
just the way i am oh yeah and um i
played myself and she played herself but
otherwise she doesn't really want to do
acting anymore um although she does have
a funny idea because she's if you've
read either of her books you'll learn
that she has a fascination with exes
her exes
my exes in fact in the first book
there's this whole crazy bit about her
and this is all true
she became
friends with my ex-girlfriend behind my
back unbeknownst to me
and had this whole separate relationship
with her just because she was like
fascinated by her right well what you
guys shared i mean yeah
she would like
i like had like the ex-girlfriend had
given me back stuff when we broke up
and and then jenny
would like slowly give some of that
stuff back to the national oh my god you
should take your shoes back i know you
gave them to jason because you were
upset at him but like they're nice shoes
just weird [ __ ] yeah
um oh dude and so anyway it's all in the
first book it's [ __ ] crazy but with
jenny you know this the story she's
writing the stories before she even like
kind of lives in a weird way yeah
and but it's all very organic i mean
[ __ ] just sort of happens to her but
she's as it's happening she's knows how
she's going to write this story
yes yes listen we've been in couples
therapy since before we were married and
we were married at nine months after we
met so oh my same therapist really
talked to her yesterday yeah um
it's been a lifesaver yeah yeah it's
been the best [ __ ] thing we've ever
invested in therapy yeah there are
things i'm sure that are just personal
enough that you can be like please don't
say well that's how we got off yeah yeah
yeah right
thank you like i'd be afraid that
something would be exposed like i don't
want people to know that i like
fart when i get excited you know
whatever it is yeah um here's the thing
i though you are very i will say i i've
always known you to be here yes i've
noticed i remember you said me once
do you remember what you know
well we were looking at apartments
in the city jenny and i and we end up in
this apartment in the lower east side
beautiful place beautiful windows great
views big and i'm like walking around
and i and the
agent the seller's agent the seller was
not there obviously with the seller's
agent was like
indic said something that no one else
would have known but i was like is your
client an actor
and is your client whatever it was i
was like is this justin long's apartment
and he was like i don't know if i'm
supposed to tell you but he smiled just
enough i was like yeah it's justin's and
i went into your bathroom yeah
how much did you do
yeah took a picture of me pretending to
take a [ __ ]
but the best was um i first just got the
text from you and it just said hey i
love your apartment or i'm in your
apartment
and then the photo was just
you
on the toilet
and i was like what it was the weirdest
thing to get because i also sort of
forgot that
i knew it was on the market but i like
didn't associate it with the thing that
other people were into right yeah and so
it was like sure i was like yep that's
that is my bathroom that's my toilet
it was really fun it was fun uh yeah so
but so yes i've always been pretty
uh open um but but there are times um
especially now that we have kids there's
some times where i will
say and by the way she she's usually she
protects there she protects it as well
yeah when it comes specifically to the
kids but but it's also like do we want
the kids knowing that about us even oh
once this is out there once they're able
to and the truth is bro there's already
some [ __ ] you know and it's stuff that
you go
you know like look uh the the first
essay that you wrote for playboy was a
story and this was what kind of got the
whole momentum going
was the story about how she hired a
prostitute for me in vegas for my
birthday
okay and the whole thing was
insane and a comedy of errors and
ridiculous and it was writing itself as
it was happening you're right um not a
single moment of it was sexy jenny is
not that kind of girl at all but it was
like enough of a like
whoa jason biggs gets a prostitute his
wife of one year gets him a prostitute
in vegas it was enough of a thing we
went on howard stern
that's all he wanted to talk about of
course was of course that so it became
this thing it actually helped
launch your book people launched her
book and
got people into her writing and so forth
but you know at the time there's no kids
there's no whatever and you know i
remember thinking like
do i want this out there yeah you know
do i well they're parents too i mean
there's my parents there's no parents of
course she writes a lot about her
parents oh um but you know ultimately it
was like you know
it's such a good story yeah and
you're writing these other stories to
not include this would be i think it'd
be
it'd be kind of a shame it'd be a shame
disservice how great a story it is
exactly um but of course i had to deal
with that for a little while still still
kind of do right because it's like oh
good for i'm glad honey that your
talents are being exposed now but like
i'm being exposed exactly yeah exactly
but um but because i'm not it would be
different i think if we were like
swingers if we were if this was on the
reg you know what i mean this is not
something this literally and if you read
the story if you hear it out of context
you might go oh yeah down with the funky
[ __ ] if you read the story you go oh my
god okay that's hilarious and insane
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello
[Music]
when you were doing the graduate i've
always been curious about this i think i
may have asked you about this uh was
that was that
a difficult decision to make doing the
graduate on broadway and just
knowing i'm sure you
idolized dustin hoffman as much as i do
and
was that did you have fears about like
you know stepping into stepping into
that i did but they were
compared to my excitement of being back
on broadway right because at that point
it had been
uh 11 years and i was a kid right so i
was in 92 i did conversations with my
father
the other
thing was it had already
performed on the west end
so there was it wasn't totally this was
the broadway debut
but but there was a bit of a track
record yeah it went nuts for it over
there like it broke all kinds of box
office records so you have this thing
that you go oh okay
it's different enough and then you read
it
and they actually um
because there was a book
uh that buck henry adapted oh wow from
the original now plastics was his r.i.p
that yeah
uh plastics was an original line buck
henry line that he put in the that was
not in the uh in the book
but the play kind of did some kind of
adapted both okay so there was it was it
felt different yeah and also it's a it's
like a broadway comedy so it felt
you know even tonally right right
different so it didn't it didn't feel
like i was stepping into his shoes in a
way it just felt like i was you know
being the lead in a broadway production
of a big comedy yeah um probably more
like yeah because that performance in
that movie is so subtle i mean most of
it is you can't even do if you try to do
that on stage yeah literally impossible
that's true so it was a way that not
only was the did the performance have to
be bigger but the play itself was was
sillier it was definitely yeah we
we you know
the
writers director you know identified the
bigger comedic moments
from the movie and really just you know
funny turned up the volume on it it was
fun man i bet you did it how long did
you do it for i i was signed for like
nine months or something but at six
months
i had an out if i got another job yeah
not anticipating that anything would
come that i'd want to like leave this
group of people and leave this
what was a hit broadway show yeah um but
mr woody allen yeah i wondered i was
gonna say i bet it was woody allen woody
allen came knocking oh my god what was
what is that like to get that call
i almost didn't believe it yeah i kept
asking because i didn't audition
um i kept i kept going well what did he
say why yeah like there was a real sense
of like i don't is he making a mistake
kind of
i guess they showed him clips of
american pie oh my goodness it's just
funny to imagine him watching american
cup right don't you wonder what he saw
what scenes he saw i i so wonder yeah i
still want him
at first i was told that he watched the
whole movie and then one day and said i
was talking to him about it he said no i
just watched some scenes i was like oh
my god okay
i was like i'm not watching that whole
thing are you kidding me
i saw the pie scene and you know that
was enough
but yeah so you go
okay i'm gonna leave to do this i guess
but i'll come back you know and so i
exercised the option in the contract and
everyone was really happy
except
kathleen was not it was not thrilled
also you had done it together with her
probably for i mean it was it had been a
long time but and also i think
maybe i'm was reading into it but uh she
had done this role in the west end it
was just her with an unknown british
actor and an unknown british actress
playing uh the catholic role so we come
now she comes back to broadway yeah and
they hire this
kid from american pie yeah and alicia
silverstone oh right and suddenly like
you know you'd leave the stage door at
night and not everyone was there for
kathleen it was like a mixed bag and it
was tiny to say i imagine you kind of
had to share the attention a little bit
and uh right
my perception of it was it didn't say
well she also was going through some
stuff personally at the time yeah um but
she i'll never
forget like we had a weekly poker game
and like the last thursday before i was
gonna you know go to do the movie for
two months or three months whatever it
was we were playing and all the other
guys it was all cast members and like
the stage manager and everyone was just
talking about it and such like jason you
know so proud of you and have the best
time whatever and
her quote i forget what it was but it
was it was it was negative oh i i wanted
something something it was something to
the effect of you know you you won't
have fun with him like he's he's really
hard and like but whatever anyway i i
it's also like when you get that call
you you you know
certainly then i mean this is you know
before uh
things change yeah um yeah right of
course but whatever like i you know
that's a bomber did you end up going
back to the play so i did end up going
back and that was crazy
because
you know a play no i was gone for like
three months wow and i came three months
they shot them something i didn't quite
anticipate i think was
the amount of
that the show would have changed
especially with another actor in the
world oh yeah josh radner oh my god wow
so josh came in and did it and you know
it becomes something else yeah sure not
me he's not you know he wasn't my
understudy where he's trying to you're
trying to go in and hit the exact same
beats you're familiar with a certain
style a certain yeah cadence came in and
did his show wow you know and
so by the time that all settled and they
now they have this show going i was i
came back and i was trying to do the old
show
and i and and i think i wasn't good at
um could have been radnord
could have been rad nurtured yeah yeah
i should have been in hindsight i should
have been
more willing
to be amenable to the changes like more
going oh okay this is where you go
as opposed to i went in and i was like
no guys this is the show that i
left and that um you know we were
directed to do
yeah
like sorry if you can't you know
not saying that but there was definitely
some friction when i went back and
kathleen of course was not thrilled and
we had a little bit of a uh uh you know
some some tense early days when i when i
first went back that's tough especially
with with you know when you're doing
something that intimate so it's very
very intimate i i say this you know
i got to give kathleen a lot of credit
she because you just said it about the
intimacy of it yeah she got naked every
[ __ ] night wow
eight times a week actually on that
stage full naked wow you know she's
[ __ ] went out and did that every
night like
i would not be able to do that yeah oh
these are short these are i'm sorry i
feel like i'm keeping you here way too
long uh all good man what is your most
commonly used emoji commonly used emoji
i guess the thumbs up really boring no
no just functional things yeah uh if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play that's a great
question
um thank you
[Laughter]
moving on uh if you're gonna
uh i would say golf professional golfer
really style's pretty great yeah you
know you're not getting cte
uh
you know hopefully hopefully you're
really clumsy you know your sponsors are
like private jet companies like you know
even if you're number 87 in the world
you're flying on a net jets plane
you know what i mean like it's pretty
good living yeah i like the idea of golf
i've never golfed before but i think i
wanna this one you know you're old too i
for the longest time i was like golf
seems like
douchey and they like clear out all this
land is for rich people and i just
didn't grow up that way or not and now
i'm like that seems relaxing it is yeah
it is seems like it'd be fun it is um
but the other one would be formula one
really i'm obsessed with formula one
really i wouldn't have guessed that the
new first i was obsessed with nascar and
i still kind of am really that happened
about 15
10 or 15 years ago i would not since you
were a kid no i did not grow up with it
and my dad will be my dad is like you're
not putting on [ __ ] nascar in my
house
it's not and i went to a race and was
you know got that vip access and was in
the pits and to go to a race and to see
it it is to be down there is pretty
thrilling yeah dude and so i was hooked
yeah and then the more into racing i got
the more people like you you watch
formula one i'm like i don't a little
bit i know it kind of peripherally but i
don't really watch it and then i watched
one race and i got hooked and also the
netflix drive to survive if you wanna um
there's a docu-series on netflix in
season two now um all about formula one
the best doesn't austin now have a
formula one track austin is the only
american uh formula one race uh-huh yeah
do you smoke you jenny's you guys smoke
we
no i don't anymore oh
more um jenny will occasionally i used
to a ton i've gotten sober
oh yeah
completely yes completely i guess that's
what sober means well there's
people have different sort of you know
some marijuana maintenance yeah uh yeah
i i just did it for
yeah it's thank you it's um
i just started this way you look so good
you look so young thanks ben i well i
plenty i i hit my quota yeah i'm not i
definitely didn't
you know i i partook yeah in access oh i
remember we've had some fun nights yeah
yeah i remember seeing you one night at
the i think it was the 24 hour plays we
really the three plays i was sure i was
pretty [ __ ] up then yeah uh i remember
one night running into you at the
roosevelt hotel
uh
[ __ ] up out of my mind i and i had
like
and the reason i remember it so well was
i had
back at my house with my girlfriend and
our friends that we were gonna go out
with at night i had gotten a bunch of uh
a beer and i dropped it and i've reached
my hand in and i slightly probably
should have gotten stitches but i was so
[ __ ] up
and i sliced my finger and i remember
walking around the roosevelt with this
[ __ ] wad of bleeding
remember that it was like it was
suggested with that yeah i'm sure i was
like on coke or something so like
friendly and just like justin what's up
man how are you i'm bleeding
yeah you were always very friendly i was
like oh that's that was super cool
[Laughter]
how long have you been so uh first got
sober about um
six and a half years basically when
jenny found out when we found out jenny
was pregnant with sid my oldest yeah
that's when i was like i gotta i just my
relationship with uh
booze and drugs was just not healthy it
was consuming it's good for you yeah
yeah yeah that's all i thought about huh
and so i attempted then but it's a
series of you know setbacks sure um so
now i have like two and a half years wow
and so weed was always a part of that
that was always yeah there was i didn't
yeah the pills we yeah uh
coke ecstasy
drinking drinking
drinking and weed like every day wow wow
but what else
we'll tell you man it's good for you i
loved you know i yeah dude i i loved it
yeah it was it was served me well for a
long time yeah
you wouldn't have had a problem with it
if you didn't love it exactly if you
were just like oh it's okay yeah
so jenny is like
you know she'll
have a glass of champagne and not drink
all of it
and be like i'm buzzed i'm like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
dude you're just gonna leave that she'll
just do like a quarter of a quaalude um
it's very impressive
uh what is your snack food that you yeah
like desert island snack food yeah uh
man
i don't even what's yours i love if it's
uh if i haven't gone to the sweet
territory yet it's uh i love cool ranch
doritos i love pizza flavored goldfish
um
i love cheez-its she's at these i really
enjoy it i can take down a whole box
i've been flying a lot of jet blue so
cheese it's a good that's my option on
jetblue yep yep
but also i do have a sweet especially
since i gave up booze sugar booth has
really [ __ ] gone through the roof
yeah one drug yeah yeah um so i love
cookies like [ __ ] soft soft cookies
so i don't know maybe i'm taking
toll house extra chewy yeah i could
[ __ ] down
in a sitting snickerdoodles
or girl scout cookies oh maybe that's
what i'm doing is it samoa is it a
samoar thin mint yeah yep yeah yeah i
like to freeze the thin mints yeah sure
they're delicious yeah uh what's your
favorite movie of all time
that's a tough one i know yeah
uh yeah it's a there's a lot of them but
yeah uh one movie i was just talking
about the other day that i wish people
could see your face when you that's why
sometimes i wish this were
how about this one how about better off
dead oh you remember better
i love you curtis armstrong curtis
armstrong i [ __ ] love curtis
armstrong yeah one of the first jobs i
did they asked me it was a tv show they
asked me who if you could who would you
want your parents who to play your
parents on the show cause the second
season they were going to have like
and i said well i want my mom i would
ideally like my mom to play my mom
because she was an actress and uh-huh
and my i'd like curtis armstrong to beat
my dad and they [ __ ] got him stop it
yeah so it was really surreal one day i
showed up at uh at lunch i remember and
and my mom
was sitting
yeah it was really cool it was really
special so cool man and curtis armstrong
turned around and he had his arm around
my mom and he was like hello son uh
[ __ ] booger it was really that's
amazing he's a such a good actor too yes
yeah better off dead yeah better off
dead in terms of its import importance
to me yes as a kid does does it hold up
i don't know i haven't watched it
but it was bobcat golf weight in that
too he
it was that one crazy summer that was
one crazy i like that one also a good
one yeah we went to nantucket over the
summer and it was that's all i could
think about was once oh yeah this was
just quoting one crazy summer the whole
oh yeah i wanted to go on vacations like
that because yeah totally
um
so good uh if you had to live somewhere
else where where would it be
um i love the mountains i love the
mountains so
you know any really anywhere any
anywhere i guess and i love this
you know skiing and winter sports yeah i
don't know it'd be dope to like
live
maybe whistler because at least it's you
know it's in vermont it's in canada
where's that no no no
no british columbia british columbia
right right yeah yeah yeah
don't know i'll tell you because it's
fake money you're right it's fake
canadian dollars oh yeah it doesn't
count right so you just kind of it's
like monopoly yeah yeah um who is your
favorite muppet
i don't know uh
gonzo i was a big fraggle rock guy oh i
love freckles so like red oh yeah i love
red yeah okay um red counts right
somewhere
right uh if you could have one
superpower what would it be
it's so cliche i mean but like what are
you know i mean i guess i'd want to fly
yeah no i just love fly i mean i guess
i'd want to fly it's funny wait i just
pictured you like talking to like the
genie the genies like you're like hey
they're just asking yeah he's like i
don't know
yes you can have anything you want jason
all right all right okay
uh if if you had to be one age for the
rest of your life physically what age
would you would you pick
uh
yeah mid-20s yeah 20 20 i'm trying to
think about well i was just at this wrap
party speaking of like not wanting to
drink anymore and you know this
phenomenon where people are like upset
when you don't do a shot with them i've
turned them down now because i the next
day i i'm just at the age where like my
body can't process it you feel it i
and time has gotten to be so precious
that i don't want to waste the next day
i don't want to i don't want to be
hungover all day so but i was like i'm
socializing and i'm laughing with you
i'm happy to yeah who cares if i put
this thing in my mouth uh if you could
be reincarnated as a non-human animal
what what would you pick
um
huh
i mean top of the food chain right oh
right
i guess a lion i mean
i'd want to be chilling yeah yeah a lion
seems like it is a great white yeah
constantly moving though constantly on
the must be exhausted yeah babe that'd
be tough this is a new one that i'm
curious how you would answer would you
rather be called unattractive or unfunny
somebody says oh yeah he's attracted
because you probably value humor more
and more yeah yeah yeah yeah well and
i've like you know i don't i've had my
own [ __ ] with my looks yeah but but the
one thing that has always
been there for me and made me feel
better and given me more validation than
i've ever gotten yeah it was like i'm
funny yeah and i can act funny and i can
be employed because i can right there's
a lot wrestling if you tell me that i'm
you know like oh you're unfunny i'd be
like
what the [ __ ]
all right hand me the noose yeah let's
go
was that funny
um
which uh which golden girl do you most
identify with dorothy blanche rose or
sophia this is also a new one it's a
that's a good one um well which was the
betty white one that's uh
that's
rose that's rose yeah blanche was um bea
arthur no no no no no that's dorothy
blanche was uh rue mcclanahan mclaren
yeah and sophia was estellgetti she was
sophia was kind of so for our listeners
because this might be a regular question
sophia was kind of like the punchy uh
sassy one who would always put people in
their place
rose was the
not dumb like dim the girl behind of it
yeah that was the betty white and then
blanche was the body kind of
how how would you describe yeah kind of
bossy vixeny vixeny yeah good that's
safe that's good uh and dorothy was uh
was the the type a alpha yeah yeah uh
maybe maybe dorothy no you've said it
all out by the way thank you for the
refresher
yeah that was great that was great man i
was like okay now i got it i should have
led without sorry it's not 1989.
i'm going to go darth vader our younger
audience is going to love this question
yeah what's up man super relatable
content
um
what about your favorite which euphoria
character do you identify um
well which do you prefer dogs or cats
dogs dogs yep uh i guess that beetle
stones
that's a good one is that tough yeah
because i like them both yeah huh have
you seen the stones in concert i have
not i'd like to i'd like to
um i'm gonna go beetles yeah i'm gonna
do beetles um
chocolate what is that there's a new one
too chocolate candy or fruity candy
uh
chocolate candy and i love skittles uh i
love skittles
how would you rank your skittles what
order would you eat them in red
and then red
oh and then red red so for the graduate
yeah my
publicist at the time got me what still
remains one of the best gifts i've ever
gotten
and it was a giant vat of only red
skittles oh wow that's but there's no
way to get them there still isn't there
was no way to order them that way he had
to do it no no
wow she's separated oh my god
i would think like who's touching all
those that's yeah but sorry sorry
when i first got coronavirus
yeah it was just getting dormant this
whole time
we can joke about it now yeah i know
it's awesome
oh that is a good gift it was a great
gift it was great but i guess but real
order
red yellow orange purple green
green being the
apple you know green is now apple i know
wow purple i i'm surprised i don't think
i've ever heard anyone say leave purple
out of their top two one or two yeah
yeah purple is a very red yellow orange
kind of the brighter citrusy for me ask
around ask people about skittle flavors
i i bet you you'll very rarely hear
purple left off the top um
meatloaf the food or meatloaf the singer
meatloaf the food if there's ever
meatloaf on a menu yeah oh i order it
okay
uh and this is a strange thing to close
with um i think i have to redo this
order what would you want your epitaph
to read do you ever think about that do
you ever think about uh legacy or how
you want to be remembered
boy i i
yes and no i guess i've thought about it
but not specifically my epic right like
all right
sorry to end on that yeah yeah yeah
great way to get in i'll tell you one
thing i have
one thing i
cause i'm obsessed with the new york
times obits uh-huh yeah my dad is too i
love them yeah i have the book of uh of
obituaries and i'll just
flip open to a random page some sort of
oh wow newsworthy person who passed away
whose life was kind of extraordinary
yeah i love it at some point in my 20s i
remember thinking
like when i was really like reading the
new york times
a lot or at least the obituary six six
seven yeah like exactly
when i could read when i learned how to
read right um and i just remember
thinking oh i feel like if i die
i would now get a new york times open
square yeah yeah and every just remember
that being such a like yeah wow
that's funny yeah yeah like i guess yeah
i mean i would
it's cool it's really good it's dark and
but yeah kind of cool yeah but you would
get a new york times right i would yeah
i would i mean i hope it doesn't happen
anytime soon
but uh isn't that funny yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's interesting so i don't know
you know exactly what the obituary would
say
the word
wouldn't mention
no no they would leave that out they
might mention the third one they might
they might yeah yeah yeah yeah
wedding they'd probably run and run that
back yeah
yeah no no sleep for uh have they talked
about boys and girls
yeah
and a reading with justin long who
incidentally passed away last week oh
god oh my god
uh
i hope it yeah i hope within a week of
each other would be nice as long as it's
like
decades 40 years yeah yeah uh
what are there more are there more
american pie things planned reunions
dude i don't know not not at the moment
yeah uh after the last one like right
away there was kind of a little bit of
momentum and talk and it did well it did
okay that's funny actually the
internationally did insane but
domestically it was our least performing
and enough to make them go
okay if we make another one we're going
to have to do this and this
by the way like
you know
i
i don't need to get paid what i got yeah
like let's have a conversation i'm down
i don't know that everyone yeah right
right no so you're speaking on behalf of
everyone yeah uh i wish i was i wish i
was you'd think it would be that easy
just be like oh okay just give me like
backhands just give me back in yeah yeah
yeah it's fine
like if you were to make it in the
spirit then you made the first one yes
you know that'd be cool uh
that'd be really cool but
you know i i don't i don't know man
anyway there's a lot of like ingredients
there's a lot of stuff
and
you know contractual stuff with the
first writer there's always oh yeah yeah
but i mean
now
uh i feel like we're
at the stage
and particularly in the environment
we're in with reboots yeah that it would
be fun to do something and maybe it's a
tv maybe it's streaming you know they
have their peacock thing but um
so maybe it's a tv version but a version
where i now because i had a son in the
last movie yeah yeah so now my son is a
teenager yeah and you're basically
casting fine who's the next who's the
next generation yeah so you're playing
the eugene levy i'm playing the eugene
level eugene is still there the
grandfather yeah yeah of course dirty
old man yeah with gray eyebrows uh-huh
and then you're basically introducing
the new that's the new generation i mean
that would be i think a win yeah that'd
be cool but um
so this show outmatched is you're
waiting to hear what happens then with
it wait in here i don't care yeah man it
was fun look i
was grateful for the job and uh i hope
we get to do it again it was a fun group
of people
and uh you know we were talking earlier
awesome yeah maggie's terrific and just
lifestyle wise it's obviously incredible
and right so you know dude look kind of
what we've been talking about you know
however many years later you know 20
something years after american pie which
is you know when i kind of for all
intents and purposes
started really working
the fact that i'm still here and even
that i could get a job in tv you know
like it's i'm so
not like i can't marvelous you're still
working
on your story but like i i i'm so
grateful yeah i really am and you know
my my
my perspective shifted a ton and and uh
i'm just like happy to have the gig and
yeah if i get to do it again i'd be
[ __ ] pumped and if not you know on to
the next thing yeah well but we'll see
an old journey we've become old yeah
journeyman you're not funny we sure have
but i i feel like you have a sense of
calm and
fulfillment you seem like very at peace
and
definitely that's nice to see because
i've always liked you so much thank you
same really safe oh yeah i'm glad we got
to do this same buddy thank you so much
forced you into this uh thanks
[Music]
well
that happened
well that was a good one yeah we were
really in sync there um
yeah yeah
and speaking of in sync they were also
very popular around the time
we talk about we talk a lot about that
time the late 90s early 2000s that time
holds a very special place in my heart
oh me too important years yeah end of
high school beginning of college the
best
a lot of firsts
god i missed that time and american
probably was a huge part of that i think
culturally american pie holds a very
special place in my heart i remember
when i saw that in the theater
i dropped my wallet
and it was on the floor or someone there
somewhere in the theater and
our father
kindly went back in
to to retrieve it for me like an hour
later when i discovered i didn't have it
and the next showing of american pie was
playing and he went in and he had to
like get on all like his hands and knees
and crawl around looking for my wallet
and he came out and he was like i can't
believe
you saw them that movie is cr he was
like blown away by how fast
the 30 seconds of that movie was that he
listened to and our father is definitely
not like a prude no um that movie it is
time yeah yeah i think we've all gotten
used to movies being really edgy and yes
and filthy but at the time in 1999 yeah
that movie
was crazy well
it's especially for someone of my our
father's generation because
you know
someone like maybe 10 20 years younger
than our dad would have already been
desensitized a bit by movies those 80
there were a lot of 80 sex comedies like
revenge the nerds porkies those
meatballs um there's some pretty raunchy
stuff in those movies
not it doesn't compare oh it kind
i just saw meatballs for the first time
and i find that you know both of you
think meatballs is overrated not
overrated but also not that raunchy
no not nearly as i you should watch
american pie again meatpost is quite
really raunchy but yeah i don't think
porky's is all right different watch
this there's a lot of nudity there's a
lot of like sexual stuff but it's not
having sex with a pie weird
and
masturbating and that's right i mean
they're pretty graphic really graphic
you're right
you're right it's pretty graphic our
father um was probably very shocked by
that
i i remember being shocked by it but it
was also the thing about that movie it's
not it's played very real all the all
the acting in that is quite grounded
yeah and we talk about that it is i feel
like as they made more sequels they got
a little a little broader broader yeah
for sure and then when they did you guys
didn't talk about this
uh the american pie presents band camp
zero oh boy yeah
which i was curious straight to video
yeah but i was curious how he
felt about that
without that franchise being being taken
over yeah it would have been a good
question yeah i think a lot of credit
and he he talks about this is due to the
director chris and paul white's those
directors who went on to do some really
other
really other other really great movies
that's their i mean about a boy is so
good i forgot they did that too in good
comfort so weird how different those
movies are
i know that's crazy though that the nc
17
rating that it was getting like over and
over again and they had to figure out
how to get it down to an r that's right
and how
they determined whether or not it was an
r based on how many thrusts he made into
the plot oh yeah yeah that was the
determining factor that's funny so weird
the mpaa is such a strange thing there's
a there's a great documentary called uh
this movie is i think it's called this
movie's not yet rated it's about the
mpaa uh nbaa
uh and it's it's so interesting i've
always wanted to see that i should see
that you should because it's it's really
like a handful a couple handfuls of
people fewer than 20 i think um
who are mostly middle-aged uh parents
it's like it's like the pta right yeah
it is it is and they're and you know
what's interesting they sometimes are
able to sneak things by them by virtue
of the fact that the members of the mpa
just don't get why something's raunchy
or gross
for example in dodgeball they got a
pg-13 rating which i think took a couple
trims
and and but even with the pg-13 rating
they were able to sneak by
some pretty like a dirty sanchez joke a
blumkin joke and if you don't know what
those things are google it google i'm
not gonna be the one to tell you but uh
they're wrong they're much raunchier
than anything else in a pg-13 movie yeah
he started to tell the story of the
opening weekend of american pie like
four times uh-huh and
and each time he started it i was so
curious how it was gonna end because he
said oh no so the movie came out on a
friday and by saturday morning
and each time you interrupted him and he
never got back oh no and i assume it was
something like it came out on friday and
by saturday morning he was getting
recognized yeah and people were like
what david hartman is his autograph or
something yeah i imagine it was that but
i'm curious oh what an [ __ ] no it's
not your you didn't interrupt him
necessarily it's just the conversation
took a different turn [ __ ] well i can
text him no i guess you did interrupt
because he was trying to say it i was
trying to give you the benefit of the
doubt
it's funny that you just sat with that
for a second like wait a minute well i
thought i realized that it doesn't make
sense yeah because if he was trying to
say something why wouldn't he said it
unless you interrupted him right he's
not gonna unless he interrupted himself
that's true did i ask him if he had
waxed his butt when he did that scene
you didn't [ __ ] i'm curious about that
because i had to do a butt scene in
going the distance and uh they convinced
me to wax it
have we talked about that on the show
i've you've told me for another episode
yeah i'll save it for another episode
uh i wonder because he doesn't strike me
as that hairy of a guy he oh really he
does me oh really yeah i think he's
probably fairly you see levy strikes me
gold order
now i think jason probably has you know
enough hair oh yeah of the main
characters in american pie
who would you guess has the most body
hair oh that's a good question
um shorties
well besides eugene levy obviously yeah
of the friends of the main characters
that's a good idea i have an answer you
i tom thomas yeah yeah he seems a little
hairy yeah he has a very strong beard
line i bet is eddie harry i'll tell you
who's not here he's chris klein
kris cline is definitely the least no
he's very smooth he's like a dolphin
yeah
yes
what's his character oh oz right
uh oh striker ah strike you know there's
a joke in um i think the fourth one that
there's a lot of like gay panic humor in
um
american
reunion where he goes he goes
jason big says something like uh
he's like oh i was voted i was
i he used like a ricky martin quote or
something it was something like oh no no
you know what it was it was big it goes
uh jim his character he says uh
uh i hope to get as many women as uh
ricky ricky martin one day and they're
looking back on their quotes and like
kind of making fun of each other and
and they're all laughing at that as if
it weren't clear enough the joke then
chris klein goes
they're all laughing and it's almost
they're almost done laughing and chris
goes
you do realize ricky martin's gay right
jim
just to sell the joke to oversell it
it is so funny um it's funny because
it's not funny he seemed to like chris
cline a lot he did yeah yeah he was a
really nice guys yeah yeah i'm not
making fun of chris cline it was a line
and i know i know um at one point you
guys talk about scrambled porn because
there's a scrambled porn scene and you
mistakenly call it mangled porn
and it was such a gross those two words
together yeah
really uh
conjured so really paint an image oh
yeah
mangled porn that's gross
you know there are of course i've
you know any memories yeah scrambled
share the spice channel sure
yeah
well maybe not all the shirts who
graduated in 1999
yes that's true but it would even out
and be like
that is a nipple it was
thrilling thrilling yeah
oh
god
he is a very good talker and
i realized that this may be the first
one of these podcasts that we've done
that there was a whole conversation like
an hour plus long conversation where
there was not a single lull in the
conversation yeah huh he's so good at
like
uh you're good at it too but you're both
so good at keeping the ball in the ball
in the air to the point where it's hard
for me to imagine him having a
conversation with anyone where there's a
lull like it was a totally lullabies
conversation yeah he's very he just
keeps it which which makes him you know
what he's doing now he's hosting stuff
and
uh presenting stuff it it it makes sense
to me that he's doing that because
that's like the ultimate yeah sure role
it's like how you got a job you know for
that job it's how you were skill rather
you were praising ryan seacrest for the
exact ability exactly but is now i'm
thinking is jason doing he is doing
hosting stuff right
he i said that but now i'm like i don't
know if that's they he does stuff for
his wife right they like game show stuff
and
yes they do i've seen them do that
speaking of the bachelor speaking of the
bachelor you seem so excited to get
through those american pie questions
you're like oh finally we can talk about
the bachelor no eddie and then he's not
watching he was like i haven't seen this
season you were heartbroken this was a
couple weeks ago this was actually i
think maybe the last one we i did before
pre-um quarantined pre-quarantine yeah
which is why you guys make a covet joke
uh sounds like it might be insensitive
oh but it's not because it was it was
before
uh you know almost what must be really
scary
to have
kathleen turner mad at you does that
seem like a really scary thing oh my god
yeah yeah
i can't i can't think of many people who
i
who would be like
more scared of to be mad
she she is so intimidated intimidating
yeah and he made it sound like she
really
was mad at him
that's a reality show i want to watch
jason and kathleen turner quarantined
together he talked about red skittles
being his favorite and how his
publicist or was it his publicist who
gave him an entire bag of just red
titles that would gross me out
oh well you made a very good observation
that
it's gross to think about how she made
an entire red battery exactly but beyond
that i agree with you but beyond that i
wouldn't want red is my favorite too oh
it is yeah so at first i was like oh
that's that's a great present that's
really nice but then i thought
i wouldn't want all the same flavor
because there's something nice about
working your your way through
your you know
less favorite flavors um flavors to get
to the red it makes you appreciate the
red ones and i think that's a good
metaphor
for life you know you don't want to have
your favorite thing all the time because
then your favorite thing won't be that
special anymore it can't all be red
skittles it's like people who go to the
fanciest like craziest restaurants get
used to that that's what i think about
people like mark zuckerberg or bill
gates and people like that who
have the means to go to literally the
best yeah restaurants for every meal for
every meal right and i wonder
if they were to do that if they would if
that food would be that great after a
while you know yeah or or you just or
the idea of having a
a big mac or
a um something kind of junky junky from
from maybe not an ad not definitely not
in it maybe from a more sustainable
company um
that uh that would they would relish the
flavor of like you know a hot pocket or
whatever it is not an ad
i felt so old when he said when he
suggested the idea which i think is a
very good idea of the next american oh
my god i know like the next generation
like their kid
16 17 graduating from high school
it made me feel so old that an entire
generation now has gone by [ __ ] can't
hardly wait
yes to think it was 22 years that was
the year before
american pie yes that's right that movie
if you happen to watch that movie
because i think it's on
hulu it's not all the time it's not a
lot but chris and i were watching and we
were struck by
how good
every all the actors were really good
but the background actors in that
amazing amazing not not just the
performances but the way they were
directed the direction whoever was the
first id or a second idea oh my god
brilliant crazy and there's so much it's
almost too lively yes it was almost
unbelievable how active that party was
yeah you know what you know i was
texting with my friend john you know
john bass uh and john said there's a
there's a background actress in that
movie
who was in another movie did background
in another movie that he and i knew
exactly who he was talking and talking
about that's how
lively and
full the background wow in that movie
but jerry i i jerry o'connell's got a
great scene in that friend of the show
friend yes a huge life is short and
saxophone player
[Music]
yeah
the amateur saxophone player
kenny g
um
kenny j um but he jerry's got a great
cameo in that where he uh oh is that my
stomach again oh my god we gotta stop
this
all right anyway watch yeah jerry's
great night but jerry's great but he's
got this burp and i was like remember
that oh did you ask him i did and he
said oh wait i gotta read what he wrote
this is really funny um i asked him
about it and apparently it is a real
burp for those of you who have seen the
movie recently you know what i mean it's
a huge burp it's like
i gotta read you what he wrote okay he
goes he does
i said you're so good on that scene is
that burberry and he said burp was real
i drank two cases of near beer and i had
to sleep
and i had to sleep on the side of the
road on my drive home
yeah oh my god
that is so funny to picture
i tried two cases of near beer i've
never heard of near beer you haven't no
is that like a barely alcohol it's like
a duels no um not an ad okay do you
wanna write a letter yes why do you let
your stomach read this one oh okay
dear guys
um the subject is
howdy to the world's longest brothers
i don't know if that's true but that's
funny in the midst of this pandemic i
can't think of a better time to
acknowledge how short life truly is and
how grateful we all should be for the
little things life has to offer
i recently found myself envying those
who were staying at home since i've
still been going to work as my as my job
involves pet health care i've seen my
friends picking up new hobbies or
working on small creative projects and
wish that i had had the time to do the
same
but i stopped and reflected on all of
the things i have to be grateful for
like the fact that i have a job a job at
all during this crisis because millions
have had to file for unemployment which
has been a nightmare of a process i'm
grateful that i have a house to live in
as those without homes across the world
have no means of protection i'm grateful
that i haven't known any of the
casualties thus far
and i'm just generally grateful for
things i took for granted before or
never stopped to notice as i think we
can all agree on how much of an impact
that can have on our happiness i hope
everyone is taking the time to be kinder
to one another and thanking essential
workers who are putting their lives on
the line daily
so
so true
thank you both for all that you do and
for providing entertainment in bleak
times justin because of the fact that
you're such a great listener
consistently unique and thoughtful in
interviews that's very nice thank you
and i'm sure that's one of the reasons
you're such a valuable friend oh well
i wonder if my friends would agree i
hope they would christian your
reflections and observations of the
guests at the end of each episode are
lovely to hear and really showcase your
intellect whether you'd like to hear it
or not
i do like to hear it ah thank you
lastly your humor combined is unbeatable
and i always look forward to the stoned
and she wrote a little like she drew a
little martian emoji looks i didn't know
they had that emoji like a spaceship a
ufo you've never seen that no what is
that how would you describe it um it is
a
huh it is a little martian ufo i've
never seen that it's a little flying
saucer i think oh it's like we're in
space and surprisingly philosophical
voice memos at the end
munch on
and much love bree
that's so nice that is very nice um
yeah but speaking of munch sean
i got a package from um
what i don't know on instagram i said
some i don't know so i
made some comments and and a company
called like
oh we gotta stop my stomach is going
bananas um anyway justin's been um
whoring himself out a lot lately on
instagram he'll go on pimping myself out
oh that's true sorry pimping yourself
justin keeps going on people's instagram
pages and being like hmm that looks
tasty and it's not bad and then and then
the company will send him like a little
like package of their product
shout out to grillo's pickles exactly
it's not i'm not doing it you're like i
love pickles
and then like four days later he'll get
a box in the mail yeah they might
they'll they'll write me and they'll say
uh well we want to send you some stuff
and i i do really like free stuff and i
love pickles so and i'm benefiting from
it too yeah i don't even have to do any
of the uh
the outreach it's funny that you're
shaming me for that because while you're
wearing a bud lucky shirt we're wearing
swag
swag why do i not know swag is dirty
weed oh yeah
but i thought swag is how you move with
with that swagger oh jesus as you did
that with your hands i tried
you couldn't have looked any less swaggy
so thanks for the letter yeah and uh
that was a great letter being grateful
and remembering all the things that you
do have i think that's very important
it's a very important way to get through
this i've been feeling such gratitude
and i'm glad you have been brie and um
and i'm grateful for your letter it's so
nice to hear that uh you enjoy the show
because we love doing it and um
we thank you for all of you who enjoy it
and who listen and uh if you want to
reach out yes our email address is
justin life is short that's not part of
it he was just saying that i should say
what it is right here i go
starting now and go address now life is
short at wondery.com
tell us how and maybe send us a question
that you think would be fun for us to
wrestle with or wrestle with anything
and thank you to jason biggs who i was
really struck by
his honesty yeah seemed like an
incredibly honest open person how he
talked about his marriage and his um
uh you know
drug
yes partying that was a surprise access
past of course i don't know jason well
um but that was still very honest and
and he's a dorothy so i like him and his
favorite skittle is red which yeah you
know i feel like i could be friends with
him oh absolutely wouldn't he be fun to
be friends yes he's always so fun to
hang out with and um
that was i loved getting to catch up
with him so we yeah we definitely thank
him and uh thanks to all of you who
listened and um
and now to listen to this another voice
memo which bree described as
surprisingly philosophical when the
pressure's on now we're fine we gotta
find a surprisingly philosophical one
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me justin
long is produced by christian long and
megan monaco senior producers michelle
miche lans audio engineer is sergio
enriquez
executive producers are marshall louie
andernan lopez for
wondering have a great week
bye
[Music]
yeah
real classic you've never seen this one
not classy just
no you've never seen american pie no
so far what do you think of it i think
it should not be a classic i i saw um
unwillingly
uh
a bit of it uh because
you had dropped your wallet
oh yeah peter remember that
how long were all the american pie in
the theater oh and i had to go in to
retrieve it why did you have to go to
these teenagers i remember that uh it
was so awkward looking under the seats
oh
what did you think did you see any of
the movies
well just a bit of it i mean i didn't
stand in a gap at it
no way but are you going to watch the
rest of it never in my lifetime you
already saw the classic that's a classic
you can really see the sequel it's more
of a classic
the classic scene when he screws the pie
it's just so
tasteless
the pie no all scripts
you